welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about your rival
who also lives in the same neighborhood
and is always trying to outdo you with
the christmas decorations every year
like what's your deal tom like what is
your problem like let me have the best
decorated house on the block this year
back off back off tom
get out of here i'm gonna fight you tom
i'm gonna fight you i'm just telling you
right now
okay
just
put your manners back in my name is mt
and i'm here today with off-screen
producer brandon what's going on brandon
uh in the middle of the snow that's so
romantic yeah
you've heard of yellow snow how about
red snow red snow oh
that's a good name for a horror movie
red snow that's right
that's actually pretty good anyway
what's our big question for today
brandon
t we got so much information from
comic-con this month so
so much information but some of the most
exciting news came during the black
panther announcements including that
trailer finally finally giving us the
trailer
forever wakanda forever baby we've been
speculating that namor would be involved
for a while now but this trailer
certainly confirmed it finally uh it's
real neymar he's coming out of the water
baby
he's coming for
mrs fantastic's wife
he's got a thing for zoo storm i mean
who doesn't who does it hide your wives
neymar's coming out of the water and
he's
been doing push-ups underwater how does
it get so built underwater i don't
understand does water aerobics exactly
if your wife's been acting fishy it's
because of neymar
get out of here
with the introduction of neymar and
atlantis coming soon to the mcu uh it's
made us all here wonder what the what
their position in the mcu will be
exactly like how are they gonna fit in
it all leads us to this week's big
question
are wakanda and atlantis allies or
enemies
enemies
enemies
with these big time rivals potentially
about to come to blows in the mcu it is
interesting to see how atlantis will be
introduced so let's take a quick look
about how atlantis and wakanda have
existed in the comics as rival nations
starting with atlantis because much like
the mythical version in our world which
is actually real um i saw it with my own
eyes while scuba diving don't you and
donovan get me started about atlantis oh
baby
the continent of atlantis
was an island which made
before the great flood
in the area we now know as the atlantic
ocean but yes atlantis is a small
continent in the atlantic ocean that
sank down to the bottom of the seafloor
many many years ago during the great
cataclysm in the comics the city was
domed at this point so some of the
citizens did survive and some of the
survivors moved to neighboring islands
however around like 10 000 years ago a
new type of being that could breathe
underwater known as homo moranis emerged
and gave rise to a new kingdom of
atlantis and it's this kingdom that
neymar would eventually rule come to
rule and uh you know be the the big the
big big man on campus the big fish on
campus the big fish with the tiny wings
on his feet adorable seriously it's so
adorable it's flying around those little
tiny wings on his ankles but neymar is
of course the offspring of an atlantean
and a human and neymar's father was
searching for a vibranium in antarctica
when he met and fell in love with an
atlantean woman and namor is able to
live in both worlds and is also a mutant
marvel's first mutant for a very long
time in the comics um and he's been in
the marvel comics for quite some time as
one of their original heroes and both
atlantis and wakanda have a lot of
similarities they both have a history
with vibranium and being technologically
advanced and atlantis needs to have
advanced technology to survive the
extreme living conditions underwater
because my god the pressure um
you know dangerous animals a lot of uh
dangerous dangerous animals dollars the
bigger fish empty always and like we saw
on the trailer that like he was he was
touching a dragon like he seems like a
dragon themed man so like i'm very
interested to see more uh sea serpents
in the mcu
well this kind of like mayan influence
is very new to the character as far as i
know like most of the representation of
the comics like they're kind of like
their own culture but i love this idea
that either they're tied to these kind
of either aztec or mayan gods or that
like they are the inspiration for it
because these you know they would go
come out of the water and interact with
like indigenous people and create this
whole world view for them i don't i
don't know it's gonna be very
interesting to see how all this ties
together right right right it's like i
love the connection there like i would
have never thought that like to connect
namor to like that type that culture
seems so interesting and they're both
isolationist nations with a lot to
protect and what condo wants to protect
is vibranium and atlantis wants to
protect its natural beauty and its
resources because and like which is
always in danger because we love to
pollute the ocean because we're the
worst oh man do we love to pollute the
ocean baby
it's our favorite thing to do it's our
number one favorite hot i just imagine
like the atlanteans down there being
like you know they're swimming around
one day they're just like
what is all these micro plastics in the
water where is this coming from
imagine about the way that wakanda deals
with atlantis and they just throw like
rings of plastic
they're just checking that garbage into
the water yeah take that take that you
fish people
in the trailer like the atlanteans were
climbing up the rope and like the
wakandans came down imagine them kind of
just threw trash at them instead yeah
it's like stop climbing stuff just like
pouring dish soap into the ocean being
like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean it did
describe in the comics it describes like
the you know you said like atlantis was
like domed as it was sinking because
like the people i forget all the history
i mean atlantis has like crazy history
but like the the soothsayers or whatever
they knew something bad was gonna happen
and so that's why they were like doming
the city but they described the dome
almost as like plastic itself so maybe
atlantis was the original plastic
polluters
they you know their dome came down and
they eventually break down and broke
into plastic
and then we discovered plastic on the
surface the guy who invented plastic
finds the piece of the dome it's like
hmm i could do something with it yeah
yeah and the atlanteans are all like
please stop using plastic we're choking
to death in our in our oceans and we're
like well
you know i really want to get a fork
from mcdonald's that i use one time so
it's really convenient for me so it's
really nice that i have these little
like ziploc bags that i can put one
sandwich in and then immediately throw
it away sorry
and neither of them you know want to
deal with the outside world but you know
i can relate to that because neither do
i and they're also both ancient cultures
have you seen the outside world it's
awful out there it's pretty terrible
don't do it and they're also both
ancient cultures that have been around
for centuries and probably why they're
also sick of dealing with the rest of
humanity because like they're just it's
been dealing with our [ __ ] for such a
long time like the atlanteans like they
fought with like tons of different
people they fought with like athens way
back in the day you know they're
involved in like world war ii and stuff
i love the idea that like both atlantis
and wakanda you know these ancient
cultures and like they i like the idea
that they're in the mcu they're both
aware of like the eternals like they met
them like many years ago and they were
like this is where we're headed screw
this
shut it down close the gates cause like
one day in each and each in each city
right or each country uh one day in
ancient history like an eternal must
like walked in like ajax comes walking
in or icarus or whatever and they're
like talking and i'm like uh-huh uh-huh
and you wanna show okay okay you want to
show okay and you want us to talk to
other okay okay i get that uh yeah we're
going to talk about it you got the
eternals come back in a couple hundred
years and we'll get over it you know
they leave and immediately as soon as
the turtles are gone like did you meet
those idiots we cannot
shut the doors we're done we're done
we're finished you guys know those are
robots from space right we don't need to
deal with that
lock them out
what i'm asking i i really do wonder if
like wakanda has experience with the
eternals because like they have to have
they but i i bet they both did and like
that's we'll get into a little later
this episode of t but like i think like
wakanda knew all this stuff about
eternals about atlantis and like you
know when when they're like oh yeah
we're gonna open up to the rest of the
world and i'm sure they were like can we
tell them about all this other stuff and
they're like no no don't tell them about
that
let them figure that out for themselves
we'll give them some we'll give them
some nano tech but they gotta learn
about the space robots here to blow up
our planet that's on them that's not our
fault and when it comes to conflicts
between the two nations they had some
some early close calls where the two
nations almost engaged in all out war
and these were mostly initiated
preemptively by wakanda when they
thought atlantis was attacking them in
one of those entities hulk was visiting
atlantis and when he left he left away
from the submerged nation with such
force and velocity the wakanda military
thought atlantis was launching a missile
which is uh you know quite the whoopsies
whoopsie and so they started launching
some missiles of their own in what they
thought was in retaliation to an attack
so uh
no whoops it's just the hulk jumping
away too fast but eventually the actual
wars would come and neymar once flooded
the entire country of wakanda in one of
the craziest splash pages i've ever seen
in my life right one of the coolest
moments of marvel history uh it was
terrible but also very cool terrible
terrible
very cool very cool and creating an
immense amount of destruction and
killing plenty of innocent wakandan
civilians so you know thumbs down from a
name war and he did contain a bit of the
phoenix force at the time but it still
doesn't excuse his actions he really
messed them up really badly so this sort
of set the stage for the icy
relationship between wakanda and
atlantic's in modern comics and during a
later disagreement queen shuri attacked
the nation of atlantis and created her
own amount of destruction and
devastation and t'challa didn't initiate
this move but it was still certainly
partly an act of revenge for the tidal
wave which you know they had to expect
it was coming because
neymar was like let's have peace like
t'challa was like you gotta talk to my
sister about that i'm not in charge
right now
uh i'm sure it was like that's a no from
me dog daymore also led thanos to
believe that there was an infinity stone
hidden within wakanda ensuring that
thanos and his black order would attack
the nation of wakanda which is quite
devious and boy did they they did so
indeed and the neymar wound up working
with the cabal in his quest to save his
people from the incursions but also
wound up destroying wakanda so you know
uh
i mean i think the infinity stone move
is like pretty clutch it's pretty clutch
pretty smart it's never it's never a
good idea to like make a pact with
thanos like it's not good but like you
know
neymar is looking out for his people and
he's like look i don't i don't know
where these things are but i heard
there's one in wakanda i i don't know
bro like that was such like it was a
terrible it was a dick move yeah like it
was such a smart move well then to like
lead the forces away from your nation to
your enemies and then they didn't
didn't he tell like t'challa later and
one of those like let him know it was me
kind of instances where he's like oh by
the way t'challa i'm the reason thanos
came and messed you up so uh i'm so glad
they're tackling the atlantis at
wakandan conflict because like that
whole situation is so messy and like the
the beef between neymar and like well in
black panther in the comics it was just
so like especially when they were both
on the illuminati so great so such good
stuff but yeah during secret wars they
were able to come to a truce in both
wakanda and atlantis were restored as
part of the conclusion of that event but
neymar had pissed off a lot of other
people in the process so you know he had
other foes to worry about but you know
that's just name warren in general
that's the name of being namor you know
he's he's not out here to make friends
but next let's talk about namor and
t'challa specifically because neymar
t'challa are often described as similar
types of leaders mainly very intelligent
and powerful but also stubborn this is
probably why they clash so much because
they're sort of very similar in types of
in those types of ways what you hate and
your enemy is what you hate most about
yourself you know exactly that's exactly
when t'challa and neymar first met they
got along fine at first you know after a
quick little fight because that's what
happens when characters meet up it's
like who are you let's fight for the
view let's go
you got wings on your feet what's going
on let's go let's go let's go
you're a freak
and the child was looking for some
missing wakandans at that point my
neymar was looking for some escaped
atlantean traders so definitely so he
could kill them for sure because namor
don't play like that so they teamed up
to achieve both of their goals but after
that encounter t'challa went all batman
all name war and started amassing all
the information he could about namor and
atlantis and how to destroy them both
should he ever need to because that's
just what a good king has to do you just
you got to be on the defense that's what
best friends do
best friends know how to kill each other
they know their work exactly like if i
ever like get too close to somebody i'm
just like yo i gotta find out your
weaknesses because like you you're
getting too close to me just in case
you're gonna like you know stab me in
the back or invade my nation i have to
know
what what you're up to but when it comes
to leading their respective nations
namor is usually always in charge while
t'challa is sometimes in charge but
sometimes just hanging out as a black
panther but they're always both quick to
put the needs of their people ahead of
pretty much everybody else so that's
always nice to do when you're a leader
and of course they have both been on the
illuminati though they didn't always see
eye to eye there but you know that's
just the nature of their characters yeah
yeah they didn't really get along when
they were illuminati you know because of
their past uh for sure they got tough
histories but yeah it was usually wasn't
it like when there were incursions namor
was always like yeah let's wipe out the
other let's wipe out the other right
easy and sometimes t'challa was like uh
maybe we shouldn't because didn't like
his ancestors at once wanted him to wipe
out one of the incursions one of the
other earths and and t'challa was like
no i'm not going to do it and neymar was
like yeah
let's go let's go neymar was definitely
more so more gung-ho about like yeah
let's destroy who cares like we have to
do what we have to do and like that's
what i like about like they're both
strong leaders both name or child are
both strong leaders but t'challa has a
lot more
compassion for humanity of course
because he's a human what i think i
think it boils down too it's like the
nature of their circumstances right like
yeah what kind is like cut off and it's
isolated but that's because it was given
this like gift of vibranium and they
were like no we're just gonna we don't
want the whole world to get it we're
just gonna stay away atlantis was like
sunk down to the bottom of the sea by by
the deviants and then they also had to
deal with like there were other there's
all these other like beings down there
underwater like the lemurians and stuff
and it's like they got all this crap to
deal with down there plus all the people
up on the land and they're just like
this is insane whereas wakanda's like oh
we have to stay secret but we have
flying cars we
and it's like
i see the chip on the shoulder that the
atlanteans really have you know it's not
a fair situation that they're in and i
feel like in the mcu like much like the
trailer is setting up and much like in
the comics how um atlantis just have
some type of roots in vibranium i feel
like the vibranium meteor that hit
wakanda a long time ago is going to be
what it the focal thing in this movie is
going to be it's because like you know
that that meteor is quite large
a lot of it probably goes into the ocean
so i feel like atlantis wants claim to
some of that meteor as well because it's
like hey just because you guys have the
top half yeah yeah we should get
everything
below sea level should be ours right
yeah i mean that'll be the interesting
point too is to see exactly where
atlantis is because in the comics it's
kind of they they describe it as like
almost the size of australia like the
original continent so like a small
continent but pretty big and just kind
of like in the middle of the atlantic
like in between north america and europe
and africa somewhere out there now if it
turns out to be like closer to africa
like that would be interesting but it's
almost like with all this you know
ancient like mayan aztec stuff that
they're setting up i wonder if it's
going to be closer to like south america
and maybe that
i don't know yeah i'm interested to see
how they explain like why they're
beefing with wakanda in the middle of
africa and not like a coastal you know
like a coastal civilization or something
mainly because maybe they were the only
two around for a while and it's like
they they just got old beef because as
you mentioned in the uh in the comics
like you know neymar's dad is looking
for vibranium in antarctica and they
haven't established in the mcu that
there's vibranium anywhere else but we
know in the comics it's in several
places on the earth because of that the
strike didn't like the meteor hit but it
also like sent it all over the world
because there was like rocks spewing up
from the crash site so yeah i think if
it's the same situation where like
someone starts finding vibranium
somewhere else or maybe like the
atlanteans start selling it off and
wakanda's like you can't do that and
they're like it's our vibranium we can
do whatever we want with it stop this
oh man like i'm so interested to see how
like in other places like vibranium is
like manifesting on mcu earth right you
know like there's also something called
anti-vibranium in the comics like i
wonder if that's gonna come but like
anyway like i just i'm so interested to
see like how other
cultures use vibranium and like if that
is that if that is like central to the
atlantean culture in the mcu because
like vibranium really does help your
society advance so much so so much it is
such a versatile metal but leading up to
black panther wakanda forever we have
had a couple of references to name more
in the mcu let's take a quick recap of
like all of those references in the past
because in iron man 2 we saw a map
during the post-credits scene that had a
marker in the general location of
atlantis in the atlantic ocean and in
captain america the winter soldier the
ship that cap infiltrates in the
beginning of the film is called the
lemarian star and lemuria was another
sunken land in the comics that was
inhabited by the deviants and so like
that's that um sunk i believe the same
day that atlanta sunk during the great
cataclysm yeah it was they're like the
neighbors uh i don't think they're gonna
do that at all in the mcu because
they've kind of established the deviants
to be those weird power ranger style
monsters that just like run around right
like i don't think they're gonna
establish oh there's a whole continent
of them also underwater like no we'll
never see the i don't i can't imagine
seeing the
lemurians in the mcu i i don't know
about that i mean like maybe cause like
we do have the lemurian star like easter
egg so like yeah i think that the
marions could factor in who knows and in
avengers end game we remember that the
moment when akoya references underwater
earthquakes off the coast of africa the
writers have said that this was not an
intentional reference to namor but you
know who knows maybe it is and they were
just trying to
throw something
they said like the writers said that
like right after endgame because
everyone was asking about it and they
were like no that has nothing to do with
that but like i'm sure
i'm sure like someone clocked that
during one of the you know reviews and
was like are you talking are we allowed
to say this can we say this and kevin
feige was like
do it
say
[Laughter]
all right i just imagine that kevin
feige in the palpatine cloak is like
just do it just do it
mention neymar but yeah there was also a
direct reference to atlantis on agents
of shield but well you know who knows
what that means who knows
who knows
they literally were like could it be on
atlantis and everyone was like
and it's like
you can't just say that
more
so it seems clear that namor and
atlantis have existed within the mcu for
some time now it's just that their
presence has not been known so do we
think that wakanda has known about
atlantis this whole time and never told
anyone i think this is like the biggest
thing right like is this a situation
where atlantis is coming out of nowhere
the atlanteans are coming out of nowhere
and for whatever reason they go after
wakanda or is this like wakanda having
to be like hi i know we said we'd open
up and start sharing things but we have
not shared this very crucial thing with
the rest of the world and now we've got
a problem
so sorry to bring this up earlier
i wonder that that's actually a good
point because like wakanda
might have told the rest of the world
about atlantis and like they probably
knew about the land lances way before
everybody else so like what does the
world do with the knowledge that there's
an underwater
nation well i'm wondering if that's shot
in the trailer where they're kind of
like opening that hole in the boat and
the people in the suits right and then
once he goes like yeah the president
being like yeah send a couple of
jumps down there let's see
let's see how they feel about it
seriously with the introduction of roxon
coming to the mcu and like i feel like
more of like people being interested in
energy i feel like maybe atlantis has a
source of energy that those soldiers
might be interested in who knows i mean
it's possible because i know i know we
brought up all the times in the comics
that like atlantis and wakanda are like
battling but they also they get along
somewhat like they have diplomats in
each other's cities which is a problem
because i believe uh neymar killed like
the diplomat from wakanda which set off
one of the one of the battles got set up
by that that'll happen but the fact that
those were set up at least meant that
sometimes they're talking and getting
along and trading and stuff like that so
yeah i think kind of like i mentioned
earlier i think it would be really
interesting if all of a sudden
you know atlantis wants to be involved
and they're like we're going to start
selling vibranium and wakanda's like
yeah you can't do that we're trying to
like prevent that and you know neymar is
just like i don't care i'm going to do
what i want to do i put this shuttle up
i put this shoulder up and i drop them
cause i don't care
i don't much care sorry about that but
they also they also look like they're
not coming to be like technologically
impressive like they look
like they're coming out just to you know
be who they are like they almost look
very less tech advanced in the trailer i
thought i don't know it's hard to tell
yeah you know like they seem very like
you know
avatar-esque and so like i do like i
wonder if like they're if they're like
sort of like pseudo like half like not
really advanced but like they have
advanced technology yeah it's like they
have like laser spears and stuff and
like that'd be really cool to see like a
weird mix of like traditional and in
modern or futuristic rather technology
with how they fight but it is it would i
think it would be very bizarre if
wakanda was not aware of them before
this film and i i hope that like it's
it's like kind of like a secret that
they've been keeping like sorry we did
not share this with you no i i honestly
now that you bring it up i honestly feel
like wakanda 100 knows about atlantis
because we saw in one if that like
wakanda was actually doing space stuff
like they were going out to space
they're doing like some weird like for
sure space excavation so like if they're
if they have the technology to reach out
to space like they've definitely scanned
the ocean and like they they have a an
idea of like the beings that live down
there i feel and like you know i feel
like because of the nature of vibranium
and how like it absorbs sound i feel
like sonar technology in wakanda is
probably much more advanced okay than
like whatever we got here so like
they've probably just detected them way
easier with that vibranium technology
but yeah do we think that wakanda and
atlantis will be allies and enemies in
the upcoming it seems like they're
setting up a battle between them right
that seems like
neymar is going to be the main
antagonist force in this film but i know
that marvel loves to throw a little
curveball at us every now and then and
fake us out i would almost like it if
they were allies wakanda and atlantis
[Applause]
and if it turns out that like maybe
they're turning away from the rest of
the world and the two of them together
are going to be like no screw the rest
of the world we're the advanced cultures
here we should be ruling everything get
out of our way like i think that would
be a fun twist but they're probably
going to be enemies of this i mean let's
be honest they're probably going to be
yes i do think that like for the
majority of this movie they're going to
be enemies and it's going to be pretty
hardcore like how hard this war is going
to be but at the end i feel like they'll
probably have an uneasy truce yeah and
just be like all right like there
they'll probably be like a mysterious
third at like second enemy that they
both have the team up and fight yeah
that's just like that
that's how it goes
the enemy of my enemy my friend or the
enemy and my friend my enemy
and like it's probably going to be the
the us government or those soldiers or
whatever those soldiers are working for
where is it come hate us
it's quite true we are quite easy today
we got tons of plastic we'll throw at
you i dare you
i dare you name so but like it really
dope to see both of those forces working
together and like you know possibly like
through the hopefully through the
compassion that they learn from the late
chadwick boseman's t'challa who um was a
very competitive like t'challa spare the
life of his father's murderer he spared
the likely spare the life of killmonger
like he was just a super compassionate
man that would just like to hear the
other side and so i feel like that might
you know be the glue that keeps them
that gets them together well and he was
trying to undo the past mistakes in the
past trauma that like his forefathers
had just kind of like brushed over and
moved on from and maybe that's a
continuation of that story like you know
moving past the past issues
with atlantis and you know the
atlanteans and trying to find chart a
new path forward and find a new way to
co-exist yeah i do feel like
king tuchaka may have done something
pretty bad to me more specifically
i don't know the record's not good we
have that shot of like the little name
we're looking at a burnt house yeah yeah
i saw that i was like uh
t'chaka i mean he was a nice man but
like he did some pretty messed up i
don't know
that well i don't know the guy
so i feel like neymar might have some
legitimate grievances um that are very
interesting to see as we see this movie
finally hopefully very soon but what you
can do right now is to head on over to
newrockstarsmerch.com to check out our
all of our awesome merch options there
because right now we have our newest
latest obsession shirt worthy of love
inspired by four love and thunder i'm
wearing one of the shirts right now very
cool and this shirt is limited edition
and won't be available for much longer
so make sure you grab it while you can
support the channel and all the great
work that we do by heading on over to
new rockstarsmerch.com and before we
dive into our bite size questions next
some words from the people that helped
bring us big question to you people like
mint mobile after years of fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by big
wireless providers if we've learned
anything it's that there's always a
catch sort of like the afterlife but
thank the gods mint noble is out there
offering premium wireless starting at
just 15 bucks a month and the best part
there's no catch mint mobile secret
sauce is that they're the first company
to sell wireless service online only and
they cut out the cost of retail stores
and pass those sweet savings directly to
you the customer many folks here at new
rockstars have made the switch to mint
mobile and they love the quality of
service that they get as well as the
savings that they get compared to their
old providers and for anyone who ate
their phone bill mint mobile offers
premium wireless for just 15 bucks a
month which is pretty amazing met mobile
gives you the best rate whether you are
buying for one or for a family and all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
with high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network so use your
own phone with any mint mobile plan and
keep your same phone number along with
your existing content switch to mit
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com bigq
that's mintmobile.com bigq cut your
wireless build with 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com big q all right brandon
are you ready for the bite size question
my friend oh i am ready empty let me
just i got to oh
[Music]
i've got one in my package
the mutant rogue only absorb the powers
of mutants this is from
wallballer33 on twitter thank you
wallballer keep ballin in rogue's
original incarnation her powers
manifested when she kissed a boy and she
liked
but she also absorbed his memories and
put him in a coma
she didn't like that part that's a
little traumatizing that's a rough first
kiss story a little bit it's gonna put
some issues uh on you
and after that you know she covered up
she's like don't touch me
it's dangerous don't you ever touch me
boy don't you touch me and the way it's
often been described is that she absorbs
the life force and psyche of who
whomever she touches that's how she's
able to get like the memories i'll take
that it's mine
if it's a mutant she touches she also
absorbs their abilities simple simple
but does this trick only work on mutants
as she herself is a mutant well that boy
she kissed wasn't a mutant was he i
don't think so and her mutant ability
still did its thing so it clearly worked
on a non-mutant so it stands to reason
that her powers would work on other
superhumans who aren't mutants right and
in fact we have some evidence that this
is true it happened in her very first
appearance in avengers annual number 10
from 1981 when she was a bad
girl
she was bad
i'm the bad guy
in that comic she took on the avengers
uh and was able to absorb the powers of
non-mutants like captain america she
just like zapped him and he like i'm too
weak
she also did it to thor too which i
think is interesting because he's like
kind of has guardians so it's like but
in those she's mainly just kind of like
knocking them out she's not really
taking their powers but
she was able to do that because she had
previously absorbed the powers of miss
marvel aka
carol danvers aka captain marvel but she
wasn't captain marvel yet because it was
still the 80s and she had to be a miss
baby she had to be the mist to the real
captain
we actually don't see that happen in
this comic it happens like off off page
and she absorbs captain marvel's powers
uh she gets the memories and that's how
she knows how to fight all the other
avengers but she also like did it so
hard that she like absorbed the power of
flight and like super human strength
that's where she gets it from it's from
carol danvers like before that she was
just absorbing people so like the power
a lot of people know her for like the
strength and the flying that came from
carol danvers because she sucked out
that power so hard it stuck and she was
like i'm not doing that again that's
dangerous so we didn't see that happen
but we do see it happen like a decade
later there's like a flashback that
shows that moment which i think is like
really fun that's always fun in comics
when they go back and explore something
right that didn't happen on the page so
yeah so she can absorb in theory like
other things you don't have to be a
mutant she can absorb any kind of powers
so i think it'll be very interesting now
that they've set up mutants
to see rogue in the marvels like have
this
kind of happen in real time because she
started out she was a bad girl she's
working with mystique you know doing her
thing they kind of touch on this in the
x-men animated series from the 90s too
they kind of go into this backstory a
little bit and also in the comics she's
trying to do it to the hulk with like
varying degrees of power copying like
sometimes she's like hulked out
sometimes she just kind of like goes
crazy so i don't know it's a mixed bag
rogue is
a lot more powerful than i feel like
people give her credit for yeah so
i feel like she she could be on like a
level a wanda esque level um if the
writers really wanted to go there like i
feel like they can write a really
interesting story with that that's the
thing in fox movies from the early 2000s
rogue is just being a jubilee stand-in
don't get me started
who's really just a shadow kit stand-in
i know i know they're all the same but
in there she she never really gets like
super powered up right she's mainly just
doing the power draining thing she
doesn't get to do her flying and like
super strong southern lady stuff so
uh yeah hopefully we get to see that
this time she absorbs the power of this
other woman
oh i i would love that if she's not
southern in this but she absorbs the
power of the southern woman is like oh
heavens to betsy it's hot outside
i do declare well i do declare that'll
be hilarious i would really love to see
rogue and cat like in the marvels like
being introduced in the marvels and like
having that like
carol danvers connection in the mcu
because like carol delmers is a huge
part of rogue's life and like vice versa
like rogue is a huge part of carol
danvers story in the comics so like
adapting that and like seeing a rogue
that can fly much like the in the
cartoons in the comics like i would love
to see that like i don't want to see
walking rogue um just you know walking
behind wolverine just following up
i don't need to see that get her up in
the air i have a fly around and toss a
building or two but thank you brandon oh
you're very welcome that's a really
great um answer to this um bad-sized
question but now it is time for our box
of scraps oh built in a cave with a box
of scraps
[Laughter]
what type of minor pet peeve would drive
you to name someone as your mortal enemy
oh oh you want to become my mortal enemy
all you have to do is get yourself a
little can uh soda your favorite sodi
pop maybe a a lacroix maybe a a beer
either okay whatever it is in a can and
when you drink it
just take little slurps off the top just
be like
[Laughter]
sit next to me and do that you're my
mortal enemy that's the worst
just take a full
drink down to me
for two hours just
just take a poultry drink
don't slurp it just drink it so you
don't like those uh asmr slurping
videos not for me dude i'm a big fan of
it not maybe not slurping but like i
love asmr that's right that's my [ __ ] be
quiet everyone just be quiet what's your
problem everyone's silence
please quiet but i love that one that's
a really i i wouldn't
it'll drive me insane drive me insane
yeah quiet what would make
hmm yeah what's the matter
what's the most petty reason to name
someone your mortal enemy i think one
minor pet peeve that would drive me to
name someone my mortal enemy is if
someone said
that frog man wasn't all that i would be
really upset if they said that frog man
wasn't gonna be the best part of
she-hulk man i'm telling you right now
whatever man is going to be the like did
you see him flying around with the jet
pack
did you see that i don't know any frogs
that fly he should be hopping if he
wants to be frog man
hopefully it's like a short distance jet
pack it's helpful to get from a to b
like i don't know like destiny or
something but like you know it'd be like
i was so hyped for that and like i i
will fight anyone who disrespects eugene
dude is my boy i want to see him fight
daredevil actually i feel like i want to
see a frogman daredevil fight that would
be that would make my life but anyway
that's my
pet peeve perfect uh people that
disrespect frogmen because he's the
truth he's the way the truth in the life
but that is it for this episode of big
question thank you to brandon for
joining me on this amazing episode
please follow him at grindenberric on
twitter you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and follow
new rockstars here on youtube and
twitter and all of our social media
platforms make sure you hit that
notification bell to get notifications
every time we upload a video and if you
want to continue the conversation join
our new rockstars discord server if
you're over 18 and interested click the
link for the new rockstar discord server
in the description below and join the
conversation today thank you guys so
much for watching we love you guys so so
much please stay safe and you know just
don't cough on each other and we'll see
you guys next time goodbye bye stop
coughing on each other
[Music]
you